and it's good marquee morris with a  three  for the lakers it's a three-point game  [Applause]  butler gets a switch now drummond is on  him they cleared out  kcp over there for help and now all the  mid-range on its way in cash for  jimmy butler he said don't do that he  talking to him saying i got the switch  and really he should be talking to coach  vogel because the switch is not  drummond's fault it is the strategy  of this team he took advantage of it  on the floor time out on the floor and  jimmy butler says your defense better  take a timeout because this is the wrong  strategy  right hand dribble as he looked the  other way sight pull up  don't do that don't do that